Well, this is a week where we're all going to be looking for the right words to say,
And I don't always know what to say.
I know that we're part of a network.
I mean, we join hands with parents and volunteers and teachers and all the people who care for
and protect and help our children,
And, after the horrible tragedy that I'm full of in Newton, Connecticut, we just really
can be at a loss for words.
At one point, though, we're going to talk to our children and we're going to talk to
our scouts about these types of tragic events,
And it's one way we can help relieve some of the anxiety and the anger and the uncertainty
we all feel about these types of things,
We can bring some perspective to them and we can find constructive action in response
to tragedy.
You probably already heard or read what Fred Rogers had to say about events like this.
He said: when I was a boy and I would see scary things in the news, my mother would
say to me: look for the helpers.
You'll always find people who are helping
To this day, especially in times of disaster. I remember my mother's words,
And I'm always comforted by realizing that there are still so many helpers, so many
caring people in this world,
And that's Fred Rogers. Mr Rogers,
I can remember myself, in 1968, when I was in second grade,
Robert Kennedy was shot and he lingered in the hospital for a time before he died,
And the events of those days loomed pretty large in our eight-year-old minds.
Were we safe?
Were our parents safe?
Why did somebody shoot Mr Kennedy?
I can remember how fearful and how uncertain we felt
When some great tragedy unfolds. our scouts are going to know about it,
They're going to discuss it and they're going to wonder what we think
They're going to have those fears and uncertainties
And we can help them by doing three things.
The first and most important thing is to talk about this.
Our scouts will see images and stories on TV and that may make them anxious and fearful.
They need to talk about these events and we need to watch for their expressions of fear
or disbelief.
We need to be prepared to help them work through this.
The best thing for us to do is to give them uncomplicated, honest explanations, reassurance.
We need to respect their emotions and beliefs, even if we don't necessarily agree with or
understand them.
In our role as scouts, I think it's especially important that we be impartial on any debatable
questions that touch on these events, whether they're social questions or religious questions
or political questions.
Our scouts are going to want to know or explain the reasons and the motivations involved
And you know, when it comes to that, our best answers are just going to be questions.
We need to ask them what they think happened and why they think it happened.
We don't need to necessarily supply answers,
We just need to listen to their answers and help them think this through,
And we can also talk about the ideals of the Scout, Oath and Law and how they apply to these
sorts of things.
I think also we can help them gain some perspective.
You know, children see the world so much differently.
Their sense of proportion and scale is really very small and they will fear. things that
have happened to others will happen to them.
They'll discuss them with each other and they'll form their own opinions, and a lot of times
these opinions will feed their fears and misapprehensions.
In the face of great tragedy, we all tend to feel overwhelmed and anxious-
I do,
I know you probably do-
And we feel a heightened sense of uncertainty, and seeing stories like this repeated over
and over again can be very alarming for children
And it can seem as though the event is happening over and over again.
We know that these feelings of uncertainty and these feelings of anxiety will subside
over time and that we begin to feel better and less anxious when we talk to and listen
to each other.
The third thing you can do to help resolve this and the hearts and minds of your
scouts and yourself is to find some constructive action.
Share the understanding that being afraid and angry or feeling sad or uncertain about this
sort of thing is natural.
We all feel that way.
What's important is what we do with those feelings.
We talk about them.
We find constructive things to do with them.
Using a letter of support or making donations to help victims, joining others in a prayer or
a moment of silence for the people who were harmed
And other constructive action is a way to join the people that help.
Now listen to your scouts and discuss these things with them and give them useful ways
to express themselves that they can use then for the rest of their lives.
That's how we do our part in forming the next generation of helpers.
If you'll go to the post that contains this podcast, you'll find a link to supporting
the helpers that will give you the addresses of the different first responder agencies
that were called to Sandy Hook School.
It's a helpless feeling for first responders when there's so much tragedy and so much
death and so little they can do,
But they were there and they did their jobs and they continue to do their jobs
And they need to know how much we appreciate that.
Finally, the work that you do as a scouter is so very, very important.
It's part of this network of care and support for our children
And we need to pay attention to them.
You have a powerful potential for doing good, for helping a child who's maybe a little
misunderstood, for helping a child with difficulties or disabilities and opening
the world a little bit for them,
And I don't think it's too much to say that these efforts, no matter how small
you may believe they are, can save so many children from the kind of despair
and darkness that had to have been behind an event like this.
This is Scoutmaster Podcast number 150..
Hey, this is Clark Green, and welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
It's been a difficult few days for all of us and there's still lots for us to do,
So we're going to just do our best to keep on moving.
Looking in the mailbag this week. let's take a look here.
We heard from Jim Patrick, who is an assistant scoutmaster with Troop 236 in
Mount Comfort, Indiana.
He says I love your blog and podcast. listening to your latest podcast on the
way home from work Monday afternoons is one of the highlights of my week.
You're providing a great service to the scouting community.
You truly do a good turn daily.
Keep up the great work
Well. thank you so much, Jim.
A lot of people listen to the podcast driving home or driving to work
And hello, keep your eyes on the road.
OK, but really thanks, Jim,
And thanks for thanks for being in touch.
It's always appreciated.
Thank you for your kind words.
Tim Georgie, who is a scoutmaster for Troop 212, wrote to say: hi, Clark,
I just read today's post on the four steps to scout advancement.
A scout is reviewed-
Great stuff.
Enjoy reading this series.
Thanks again for all you do for the scouting community.
Your blog is one I look forward to each day,
as is your podcast each week.
Thanks so much, Tim.
That's a familiar name
And I'm glad to hear back from you.
Steve Chase works with Cub Scout Pack 940 in San Antonio, Texas.
Down there in San Anton
He says this: I found your blog last month
after I became a new den leader with my son's Wolf Den.
Thanks, Clark, for your valuable and inspirational podcasts.
I've had a chance to listen to about four or five of them
and they've all been outstanding.
I did want to mention that podcast number 69
was very special to me.
Thanks for sharing your story about being a dad
and going through the different years with your son.
Your words seem so right and so good for me
to hear as a young father myself with four boys.
Thanks so much, Steve
Boy. you got your hands full for you, my four young boys.
Being a Wolf Den leader is really intense.
I used to call that the most intense hour or so of my week.
More power to you and thanks for listening
and thanks for being in touch.
Jeff Richard is in Little Rock, Arkansas, with Troop 99.
And he wrote in to say I love listening to your podcasts.
And the last message this week comes from Bill McFarland,
who is a longtime listener to the Scoutmaster podcast.
He works with Troop 8 in Pittsfield, Massachusetts,
And he said this. a really interesting thing
happened the other day when my cell phone rang
and apparently Bill's got the introduction we usually
use in the podcast.
And now to you Scoutmasters, Baden Powell-
followed by the Bugle call, the first call.
After I got off the phone. one of the people I was around
asked me how she could get that as a ringtone.
When I explained it came from your podcast
about scouting and she couldn't understand
what that had to do with horse racing.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha ha.
Yeah, first call, you know, da, da, da, da, da, da, da da.
That's the Bugle call and that's
why it's at the top of the podcast.
That's the first call that goes off in the morning. right,
I don't know about you, but that's
what we hear over the PA system as the first call
in the morning at our summer camp,
And I thought it would be a great way
to start the podcast off.
Of course, if you go out to the racetrack,
you hear that call and that's post time.
Yeah,
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha ha.
thanks so much, Bill.
It's always good to hear from you.
In this podcast we have the fifth and final installment
in our series about scout advancement
And we'll be talking about the last step to advancement:
A scout is recognized,
And then we've got some email questions to answer.
So that's going to make a pretty full podcast.
Let's get started, shall we
Scout Master Ship in seven minutes or less.
So, as I said, this is our final installment
in the steps to scout advancement.
There are four steps to scout advancement.
Number one is a scout learns.
Number two is a scout is tested.
Number three is a scout is reviewed.
And number four is a scout is recognized,
And we're going to be talking about that fourth step today.
Let's go to several of the resources that we have.
The first is the Guide to Advancement 2011..
And it has this to say. it says:
immediate recognition is a powerful incentive
of the Boy Scouts of America Advancement Program.
A scout should receive his new badge
as soon as possible after his achievement
has been certified by a board of review.
A simple ceremony at the conclusion of a troop meeting
or during a campout is ideal,
with the Scout Master making the presentation of the badge.
In addition, a troop holds a court of honor
every three months, a formal recognition
with families, friends and the public in attendance.
All scouts who have moved up to any rank
or who have earned merit badges
since the last court of honor should be recognized.
The Scout Master Handbook echoes this when it says
when the board of review has approved his advancement,
the scout deserves recognition as soon as possible.
This should be done at a ceremony
at the next unit meeting.
The certificate for his new rank may be presented later
during a formal court of honor.
The Guide to Advancement also notes
that the board of review date,
not the subsequent court of honor date,
becomes any rank's effective date.
So in cases where tenure starts being counted,
it starts being counted from the board of review date,
not the court of honor date but the board of review date.
The troop committee guidebook echoes the same directions.
It said when a scout advances
he should be recognized as soon as possible,
preferably at the next unit meeting.
He has recognized a second time
at a public ceremony called a court of honor.
The main purposes of the court of honor
are to furnish formal recognition for advancement
and to provide incentive for scouts to advance.
Formal courts of honor should be conducted
at least four times a year.
All scouts who have advanced
since the previous court of honor are honored.
Their parents and friends
should be invited to attend the ceremony.
Suggestions on court of honor agendas and ceremonies
are found in troop program resources for Boy Scout leaders.
So after having read those resources
we see that in the fourth step of scout advancement
a scout is recognized twice.
He receives the badge or emblem as soon as possible
and he's also recognized at a court of honor.
As far as I can tell, every advancement award
offered by the Boy Scouts of America has two components:
There's the badge itself
and there's a certificate that goes along with the badge.
Now, that word certificate confused me
for a long time. as a young scout master
I was looking for a certificate
and what they're talking about is the little card
that comes along with the badge
that usually the scout master
and the senior patrol leader sign
when it's a rank advancement
And for the higher ranks,
I think that there's even a signature slot there
for the troop committee chair.
What we are directed to do
is to present the badge as soon as possible
and then we hold on to the card
or the certificate to present at a court of honor.
So a scout needs to get that badge
as soon as possible
after the achievement has been certified by border review
or we've recorded a merit badge or something like that.
Let's get him that badge right away,
let him sew it on his uniform,
let him put it on his merit badge sash.
I mean, the whole idea of this first presentation
is getting it to the scout.
He's earned it, it's been recorded properly
and we want him to have it as soon as possible.
There's no reason it needs to sit around
for weeks or months waiting to be distributed.
The Scout Master Handbook mentions a simple ceremony.
The way it works for us is that our advancement chairman
will give me the badge and the certificate
and I will hand the badge to the senior patrol leader
at the closing of our troop meeting
and I'll hold on to the certificate
so he can read the name.
The scout steps forward,
receives the badge with a handshake
from the senior patrol leader,
His fellow scouts give him a little round of applause
and that's it.
It's very, very simple.
You notice that it also mentioned
that you can do this at a camp out
and that would be great.
Round of camp fire at camp out. very simple presentation
and noting. you know we're going to recognize this
more formally at our next court of honor.
So that's the first time that a scout is recognized
when he gets that badge.
The second time is going to be a more formal recognition
at the court of honor,
Periodically, and every three months
is recommended in all the literature.
a formal court of honor is held to recognize ranks
and merit badges and any other achievements.
since the last court of honor,
I don't know of any official policy
or directions from the Boy Scouts of America
describing the way to hold a court of honor
or any particular rules about what has to happen
at a court of honor.
You'll find lots and lots of suggestions
for courts of honor in the troop program resources guide
and these are of course suggestions.
These aren't necessarily directions or policy statements.
When a scouts completed his border review
and the paperwork has been signed,
he was moved from the next rank to another.
It's already happened.
A court of honor only recognizes that achievement,
It does not bestow the achievement,
And I think that's an important concept to note,
because the date of the border review
is the effective date of the award
and not the court of honor date.
If a scout becomes first class at his border review,
whatever the date of that border review was,
begins his tenure for star, and the same applies
to star and life as far as when the tenure officially begins
for fulfilling the tenure requirement for the next rank.
And while I don't run into this very often,
every once in a while,
somebody has the idea that a court of honor
is like a wedding ceremony or swearing in a public servant,
where some combination of actions and words
actually changes a person's status
as a result of the ceremony.
Courts of honor aren't like that.
Courts of honor are just recognitions
of something that has already happened.
Now, nearly every troop has their own specific way
and their traditions surrounding a court of honor,
and I wouldn't ever say any of them
were just flat out wrong.
I prefer some ways over others,
but that's just my personal preference.
So what follows are my own ideas
about the way things ought to be,
And so when we're listening to this,
remember from here on out:
this is just my opinion.
These are not policy statements or directives
given to us by the BSA. okay,
I think, first of all, that simplicity
and predictability and consistency
are three really important elements
of a good court of honor.
Simple, predictable ceremonies
that are presented consistently
have a lot to recommend them,
and I think that they really help our scouts
appreciate exactly what's going on.
If we choose a ceremony and we kind of stick to it,
scouts are going to be familiar with it.
There's going to be fewer terrified, vacant stares
from whoever's presenting awards
and whoever's emceeing the ceremony
and there'll be a lot less uncertain
kind of wandering around and shuffling of feet.
And if you've been to several different courts of honor,
you probably understand exactly what I mean.
I think it's good that awards
are presented the same way over time
So there's a consistent recognition of the same award
from one year to the next. for all the scouts,
Merit badges are presented the same way,
badges of rank are presented the same way,
and that that consistency sends a message
that everyone's achievement is weighted the same
and it means the same thing.
Repetition also brings home the messages of the ceremony.
If we change the ceremony up every single time,
in my opinion, I think we end up missing some things.
I can also see the virtue in different ways
of saying things, but I stick them with the idea
that the repetition helps bring home the message.
And simplicity, finally, means brevity.
Let's keep the audience interested and engaged.
Let's not let these things drag on a whole lot
and have a lot of extemporaneous talking
and things like that.
Let's keep them brief.
We've used the same basic court of honor script,
with a few changes, for probably about 20 years or so.
You'll find all manner of ideas
of court of honor scripts online
and there are even books about eagle courts of honor.
There's plenty of ideas out there.
I'm saying, keep it simple.
And I'm saying this because, having written
and directed two plays and acted in many more,
I can tell you that dialogue and blocking
and scenery and costumes and the theatrical aspects
of staging a play require about two or three people
behind the scenes for every person that you see on stage.
So what you see from the audience
if you go to see a play is just the tip of the iceberg.
If you have the resources and energy
for an elaborately staged court of honor
will more power to you
If you wanna change the script every time
and you wanna do it differently.
like I say, more power to you
What you may not know,
especially if you're just starting a troupe
or have just started your tenure as a scout master.
once you've staged a big, elaborate court of honor
and put a lot of energy into it
and gotten a lot of people involved in it,
you've set a precedent and you'll be expected
to meet the precedent of that big, elaborate court of honor
for all subsequent courts of honor.
That's another aspect of this
that kind of recommends simplicity in my mind.
I would also suggest that your youth leadership,
led by the senior patrol here,
do all the presenting at courts of honor.
Our courts of honor are MC'd by our senior patrol leader.
There's no adults up there
and he invites me, the scout master,
up to the stage to help him present ranks
from first class up. but that's my only part in it.
Now, while a good court of honor
should have some formality and gravity
commensurate with honoring achievement,
they don't need to be stilted and uncomfortable.
There ought to be a lot of smiles
and the inevitable mistakes that are made
in the presentation should be taken pretty lightly.
Nobody gets laughed at, no horrified gasps
from the audience if something goes wrong
and no reason for anybody to feel bad or to be embarrassed.
But we still wanna maintain that atmosphere
that something important is happening.
And I do wanna take a moment to talk a little bit
about Eagle Courts of Honor.
You know there are folks who insist
that the Eagle Court of Honor
must be a separate presentation
from a normal court of honor.
Some troops have the tradition
of holding separate presentations
for each individual Eagle Scout
and some present the Eagle Award
as part of a more or less normal troop court of honor.
I can't find any rule to follow about that.
I think either way is just fine.
Some troops delegate planning the Eagle Court of Honor
to the scout and his family,
And if that works with you, fine.
I think it can lead to problems
And I know I say that because it has in the past for me.
Some parents lose the distinction
between what an Eagle Court of Honor
and a coronation is. okay.
One huge, expensive, theatrical Eagle Court of Honor
can set a precedent for the next family
to meet or surpass,
And soon you may end up with this upward spiral.
that's hard to stop
And, like I said, I've seen it happen
And it can get kind of difficult.
So what I mean by that? think about this.
Think about a catered reception with a live band. okay,
Does that sound a little over the top?
I've seen it happen.
And then that creates the expectation
for the next family, who may not be as well to do
or may not have the energy or the resources
to put into something like that.
And now we're working with a can of worms.
Besides those considerations,
I can also tell you from having talked
with a lot of Eagle candidates over the years:
a lot of them prefer a simple, meaningful, brief-
and emphasize the word brief- ceremony
than a really big show. okay,
Some guys they're into the big show
and everything like that. that's fine.
I will tell you that some years ago,
after a lot of fuss and bother
and uncomfortable committee meetings
and heated arguments and hurt feelings,
we finally agreed to hold our Eagle Courts of Honor
as a part of our regular troop courts of honor.
We make our courts of honor
where we're presenting an Eagle Award very, very special.
It's not just handing out the Eagle rank
as if it was just another rank,
but we kind of have a description.
that keeps it all pretty simple
And thus far everybody's pretty happy about it.
I'll say again, we read the resources
and commented a little bit on the resources
and then I gave you some of my thoughts,
not policy statements or directions,
but just my thoughts about the court of honor.
So the last step of scout advancement is
a scout is recognized twice.
He gets recognized as soon as possible
after all, the paperwork's done
and the badge is in our hands.
We make sure that he gets the badge
at a simple recognition ceremony
at the end of a troop meeting or on a camp out-
Doesn't have to be a big deal
And then he gets recognized a second time
more formally at a court of honor,
and suggested the courts of honor
should be held about four times a year,
about every three months.
You'll find some links to the resources
that we shared here on the post
that contains this podcast at scoutmastercgcom.
["To Smile When You're Happy"].
To smile when you're happy.
To smile when you're sad.
To look pleasing
World mystery.
To be calm
When you're mad.
Oh, be forgiving,
Somewhat abusing,
For the good Lord.
Look for such
Dear Roddy's day and smile
On your way.
Don't cause very much.
Oh, head down,
Cause very much.
Where to place the gentle touch
To give a glass of water
To a pilgrim in need of sight.
Oh, you may not be an angel
And you may not go to church,
But the good that you do
Will come back to you.
It don't cause very much.
Write me a letter,
Send it my name,
Email, that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails:
["To Smile When You're Happy"].
So I've got two email questions that came in this week.
Derek Morton is with PAC-780 in Vale, Arizona,
and he wrote to say this:
Clark, great podcast and blog posts.
I've been listening for some time
and I always find myself waiting for the next one.
I'm currently a Weebelos 2 den leader.
My plan is to start a troop in our local area.
I'm an Eagle Scout
and I've been involved in scouting for many, many years,
but I've never started a troop.
My question is this:
does the BSA have a guide to starting a troop?
I've spoken at length to our council and district
and to the commissioners,
but I can't find anything in writing from BSA
on starting a troop.
Searching the internet has produced the same results.
What am I missing?
Well, first of all, Derek, good on you for stepping up
with the idea of starting a troop.
It's a wonderful thing to do.
You should be able to get a lot of support
from your district and council folks
as you go through the process.
The resource that you're looking for actually does exist.
It's hiding in plain sight, right.
This is what you need.
You need a copy of a scout handbook
and the scout master handbook,
the troop committee guidebook
and something called
the Chartered Organization Representative Pamphlet,
And I'll link you to a PDF version of that
in the post that contains this podcast,
Since these resources all correspond
to three key people who will get a new troop going.
I would get those resources.
I would get these three people-
the scout master, the troop committee chair
and the Chartered Organization Representative-
to sit down with all those resources
and start mapping out a plan
for the first year of the troop.
I promise you'll find all the information
that you need in those resources
And by the time you do this
you'll be very conversant with those resources
and how things work.
I like that idea better
than creating a how to start a troop book.
I think it's well worth the time
to sort it out on your own.
Now. you didn't ask me for this advice,
but I'm pretty good in offering unsolicited advice.
Don't even think about trying to do this by yourself
If you don't have those three key people-
the scout master, committee chair
and Chartered Organization Representative.
get them lined up first
And the three of you get together
and make a commitment to each other
for at least maybe three years.
Don't improvise, don't customize.
do it by the book and refine your approach
as time goes by.
Don't sweat the council paperwork.
Any district executive worth his salt
will show up on your doorstep
with the correct paperwork
and help you fill it all out.
There's one form for starting a new unit,
one form each for the scouts
and adults involved. and that's about it
From a paperwork standpoint.
it's really very simple.
You're gonna have a grand time.
Keep in touch, Derek,
and let us know how things go
and let us know if we can be of any further insistence.
And, once again, thanks for getting in touch.
This email question comes from Iowa.
How would you approach a scout master
that withholds positions of responsibility
from the boys at star and life rank
because the scout master contends
they do not have scout spirit?
Well, first of all, thanks for getting in touch.
I gotta tell you, when I got this email,
I laughed out loud
because my first reaction was:
I would approach a scout master doing this,
probably with a pointed stick,
And oh okay,
None of us are going to do that. all right,
I understand,
But that sort of thing is tempting
when somebody gets stuff that wrong.
I hear about this type of scout master
on a regular basis.
So let's talk about a few ideas to handle this.
Assuming that the person who sent me this email,
their son, is a scout,
They've been told by the scout master
that they are lacking in scout spirit
And that lack of scout spirit disqualifies them
for a position of responsibility.
And since the email mentions both star and life ranks.
I get the impression that this scout master
has a habit of doing this.
He's wrong,
And he's wrong in several ways.
Most importantly, he's wrong about this
because he hasn't read or remembered
what's in the scout master's handbook.
One of the things you'll find there
is that the positions of the senior patrol leader
and patrol leader are democratically elected
by the scouts.
The troop can set some very basic expectations
to qualify for the election.
These may be age, or they may be rank
or something like that.
I would never, ever set a judgment call
kind of thing where the scout master
then becomes the gatekeeper for who gets to stand
for election. like a scout spirit,
I just would recommend against that.
Every other position of responsibility
other than junior assistant scout master
is appointed by the senior patrol leader,
And the exact wording you find
in the scout master handbook is this:
Depending on the size and needs of a troop,
any or all of the following positions may be filled,
And then it goes on to list those positions.
Unless indicated, the senior patrol leader
selects the scout who will hold each position.
The scout master can help, can help, can not must.
He can help the senior patrol leader
make his decisions on the basis
of candidates overall qualifications
rather than merely on friendships.
So our problem scout master here
is trying to become the gatekeeper
and impose judgment where it really doesn't belong.
Some of the youth leaders are elected democratically
and some of them are appointed
by the senior patrol leader,
So this is a youth based decision.
He's also missed the fact that we motivate
and support our scouts by responding
to and enabling their aspirations,
not by keeping them from those aspirations.
I'll tell you very clearly that I've had doubts
about a scout's suitability and ability
to take on a position of responsibility,
But my job is to encourage and motivate him
to do the best he can,
Not just to say, hey, I don't think you're up to this,
so forget about it, right?
Some of my best youth leaders
were really shaking and uncertain at first
and a lot of times all they needed
was someone to believe in them
and that they had the capacity to do the job.
How can anybody think that telling a boy
you know you don't qualify
because you don't have enough scout spirit
is going to motivate or encourage them
to have more scout spirit?
If I was a boy and somebody told me something like that,
I think I would turn around, walk away and never come back.
We know that what you're telling us
the scout master is doing sounds wrong.
So what do you do about something like this?
Well, it's really not up to you alone.
This is up to your scout.
He ought to educate himself a little bit
by reading a scout handbook,
and even looking at the scout master handbook,
about how these things are supposed to work.
and then he ought to stand up for himself
and go to the scout master and say:
you know, I really don't understand
why you're preventing me
from taking on a position of responsibility.
If a number of scouts get together and do this,
that scout master just may change his tune.
Now, this requires some backbone
and some hutzpah
and it requires a scout to be brave,
but it would be a very, very good thing
for him to be able to do
Now. if they give this a shot
and they don't get anywhere, then,
and only then, I think it's time for parents
to get together and to go to the scout master
and ask him to explain why he's doing what he's doing
and how he justifies what he is doing
according to his training.
If the parents don't get what they consider
to be a reasonable explanation,
then I would get the parents and the sons together
and I would talk about finding another troop
who, scout master, understands the program
and then you vote with your feet
on the suitability of that scout master.
I don't think it's necessarily a great idea
to try and change the troop,
and I don't really know from this email
what all the extenuating factors are
about this particular troop.
I don't know how long this scout master
has been around or the relationship he has
with the troop committee,
If the troop committee is a paper committee
or if it's actually functioning,
what kind of shape the chartered partner relationship is in.
Maybe the best thing to do in this case
is to find out who the commissioner for the troop is
and ask their advice.
I will tell you two things
that I would prefer no one do
when they're in this kind of a situation.
One is to hold conversations
or make accusations or do anything by email.
When you're confronting this type of a problem,
you better do it all face to face,
and here's why
People will say things in email
that they would never say in person.
Email's not contextualized by standing there
and talking to a person
and hearing the tone of their words
and seeing the expression on their face
and boy, things can go south really quick
when those emails start getting distributed around
and I don't really have to tell you
what happens after that, do I?
Finally, I don't want anybody to use me
as the authority on any kinds of questions like this.
If you wanna share my opinion on things, that's fine,
but how would you feel as a scout master
if some parent came up to you
and said: I found this guy on the internet
and this is what he told me,
and no, no, you better be sure for yourself
that I'm right by going to the sources
that are provided by the BSA.
If I'm wrong, let me know,
because you'll be helping me too.
Hey, we're all making this up as we go along, aren't we?
We're all learning as we go along.
Most of this literature,
most of these things are pretty easy to find
and use those.
There's the authoritative resource,
not the guy on the podcast
or the guy with the blog. okay,
And I think that that's just a very important rule of thumb
to observe for any question about scouting
Iowa. I appreciate you being in touch.
I hope what we had to say here helps
If you have a question or a situation
that you think I might be able to help you with.
do get in touch
and you're gonna find out how to do that in just a moment.
Hey, thank you so much for listening to this edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how you keep in touch:
Go to scoutmastercgcom.
There you can read the blog
and you can subscribe to receive updates
to any articles we put on the blog by email.
Subscribe to the Scoutmaster podcast on iTunes
and, when you do, if you have a moment,
leave a comment or review or a rating
and you can access this podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you can get details about how to do that
at stitchercom.
You can experience all the complex
and beautiful wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
You can follow us at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
tweet ScoutmasterCG on Twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive ScoutmasterCG circle,
Search for ScoutmasterCG on Google+.
If you don't participate
in the vast panorama of social media, email me.
Hey, that still works right.
I'm Clark Green and you can email me
with your comments and questions at scoutmastercg at Verizonnet.
I can't say it often enough,
but the Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor do they carry the endorsement
or sponsorship of the Boy Scouts of America.
It's just me talking into a microphone
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and, you know, have a little bit of fun along the way.
So before we go, let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.